>>> MY FELLOW CONFORMISTS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE APPROVED WAY
TO SIT ON THE TOILET.
IT HAS BEEN DESIGNED TO MAKE YOU
LOOK STUPID AND FEEL FOOLISH.
IT IS AGAINST REGULATION TO LOOK
COOL OR FEEL CONFIDENT ON THE
TOILET.
THIS IS THE WAY IT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AND MUST ALWAYS BE.
>> NO.
>> WHAT IS THE MEANING OF THIS?
GO SIT ON YOUR DESIGNATED TOILET
AND FEEL SHAME.
♪♪♪
>> THAT TOILET IS DIFFERENT.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> THE FUTURE.
♪♪♪
>> IMPOSSIBLE.
NO CITIZEN CAN LOOK COOL WHILE
SITTING ON THE TOILET.
THIS CHANGES EVERYTHING.
NO!
>> INTRODUCING THE COOL TOILET
BY KOEHLER.
A SLEEK REVERSE BOWL TOILET THAT
YOU SIT ON THE COOL WAY.
BACKWARDS WITH YOUR ARMS
CASUALLY DRAPED OVER THE TOP.
THE CRAFTSMANSHIP YOU EXPECT
FROM KOHLER COUPLED WITH
REVOLUTIONARY DESIGN IT BRINGS
CONFIDENCE INTO THE BATHROOM.
>> NOTHING WILL EVER BE THE
SAME.
>> THE COOL TOILET BY KOHLER,
COMING SPRING 2017.
ALREADY AVAILABLE IN JAPAN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]